- Many of you in this
room know me and you know
I pride myself on my work ethic.
But buddy, I met my match.
- [Commentator] Elon Musk
has chosen Linda Yaccarino,
NBC Universal's former
head of advertising,
to become the new CEO of Twitter.
Musk confirmed the
appointment on May 12th,
a day after saying a new CEO
would start in about six weeks.
Suzanne Vranica covers the advertising
and marketing industries
for the "Journal."
She explains Yaccarino's background
and what her selection says
about the direction
Twitter could be headed.
- Hi, my friend.
- Linda Yaccarino is probably
the best known ad salesperson
there is on Madison Avenue.
She's got a flamboyant
and outgoing personality.
She's got relationships that go
from Silicon Valley to New York.
She knows marketers by first name.
She knows their kids and
she knows how to do her job.
One media buying farm
calls Linda Yaccarino
the Velvet Hammer.
And the reason for that little nickname
is because she is one tough cookie
when it comes to getting money.
She can come off
as the friendliest person
that you've ever known,
but when they're in negotiations,
look out, she's tough.
This is a real signal that
Twitter needs this person
to reverse the advertising
slide that they've experienced.
- You really need no introduction,
but in many ways today
is your introduction
to the advertising community.
Right?
- Hello, hello.
- I think that's a round of applause.
- [Elon] Hello.
- [Suzanne] Miss Yaccarino
has been warming up to Elon
for a couple months now and
she conducted an interview
in Miami with him recently
and what was apparent
from that is they both shared kind of
the same vision for what
Twitter's going to be.
- If freedom of speech, as he says,
is the bedrock of of this country,
I'm not sure there's anyone
in this room who could disagree with that.
Could I get a round of applause for that?
- She very much believes
that it should be a place
for free speech which is what
Elon has been talking about.
He's very adamant and making sure
that Twitter has different voices
and opinions that can be heard.
Following Elon Musk's takeover of Twitter,
advertisers exited big time from Twitter.
They were really afraid
that Elon would lift all restrictions
and their ads would be
appearing near unsafe content.
That has basically kept a lot
of them at bay and they have not returned.
Linda Yaccarino knows full
well that this is an issue
'cause she used to use this
to her advantage when she was at NBCU.
She would attack the digital channels
for having content that
was too controversial
and hoping to make sure
that brands would stick
with big broadcast network for safety.
So I suspect that she'll make
sure that Twitter invests
in new tools to keep brands
away from unsafe content.
The biggest challenge I think
that Linda Yaccarino
will face when she heads
to Twitter is Twitter is run
by a bunch of engineers and coders
and that's an experience that
she doesn't have much on.
The good news is that
Elon has already signaled
that he will handle the majority
of that part of business,
but it'll interesting enough to see how
these two actually learn to work together.
(light music)